THIS COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WILL COME TO ORDER AND THAT
INCLUDES MR WHY CASKEY. GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME TO HEARING
OF THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IN
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE- STREET BUILDING.
AND I'LL ASK FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY TO COME ON
DOWN. SO WE CAN HAVE A QUORUM TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY VIA PHONE. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE. I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN SIX TWO. TWO FOUR SIX
TWO. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES FROM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AND OR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
YES THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE. THERE WAIT
MAYBE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
I NEEDED AND YOU'LL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND UNDERSTANDING SO
REMEMBER. MUTE YOUR PHONE. WHICH
SHOULD BE MUTE THE- I THE DEVICE
YOU'RE WATCHING US AS YOU TALK
ON THE PHONE. OBVIOUSLY I
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE- HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. IT'S ALSO A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS IS
A FISCAL COMMITTEE SO PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY. TO THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THE BILL YOU
ARE TESTIFYING AND REFRAIN
REFRAIN. FROM REPEATING YOUR-
TESTIMONY FROM THE POLICY
COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT GOING TO RE
LITIGATE THE POLICY. WE'RE JUST
GOING TO FOCUS ON THE FISCAL
IMPACTS. RIGHT. SEVEN SEVEN TWO.
HEY SO WE HAD A TYPO IN OUR
PHONE LINE IT IS. 877-226-8163.
984-487-7226 EIGHT ONE SIX THREE
SO MAKE THAT NOTE. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN NINE EIGHT TWO EIGHT FOUR
FOUR ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TWENTY
FIVE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA AND
ALL OF THE MEASURES ARE SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAS INFORMED US THAT
THEY DO NOT HAVE ANY FILES FOR
ANY OF THE BILLS WE ARE HEARING.
AND THE REPRESENTATIVE WILL NOT
BE HERE PARTICIPATING TODAY
BEFORE WE TAKE TESTIMONY ON THE
BILLS OBVIOUSLY ALL ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WHICH WERE CHALLENGED IN
THAT EFFORT AT THE MOMENT WE
NEED ONE MORE SENATOR SO WE'RE
GOING TO- I WILL CUT THE
MICROPHONE OFF FOR A MOMENT AND
WE'LL WAIT. FOR ONE MORE SENATOR
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD.
MISTER CONSULTANT IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH SHARK FARMS SENATOR
PORTANTINO I'M HERE PORTANTINO
HERE SENATOR BATES. SENATOR
BRADFORD SENATOR JONES. CENTER
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER HERE CENTER
LAYERED LAYERED HERE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE HERE CASKEY HERE FOR
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
QUORUM- DUE TO CAN. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LANCER
HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONSIN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
INSTILL A TIME LIMIT AND WITNESS
TESTIMONY SHOULD IT BE NECESSARY
EACH SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED. A
TOTAL OF FIVE MINUTES OF TIME
FOR PRIMARY TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIMONY TESTIFY
WILL LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION IF NECESSARY WILL ALSO
LIMIT THIS ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
TO TEN MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE.
AND AS A REMINDER ALL WITNESSES
SHOULD LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE BILL AND
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY- SO I WILL STRICTLY
ENFORCE WHAT WE COMMONLY CALL
THE ME TOO- WHICH IS NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE RIGHT TO OUR
FIRST BILL WHICH IS EIGHT THREE
TWO BY SENATOR DOT ON WATER
RIGHTS MEASUREMENT. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION SO- RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
ROOM TWO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT THREE
TWO. BY SENATOR DODD. SEEING NO
ONE COME TO THE MICROPHONE WILL
GO RIGHT TO OUR- PHONE LINE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
SUPPORT. FOR SB EIGHT THREE TWO
NOW WOULD BE THE TIME. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF FIFTY EIGHT THREE Q. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. THAT IS ONE THEN IF ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT WILL GO TO OPPOSITION IS
OR ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED OPPOSED SB EIGHT THREE
TWO. SEEING NO ONE HERE WILL GO
TO MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED EIGHT THREE
TWO. HEY WE CAN OPPOSITION EIGHT
THREE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND YOUR PHONE. THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
IN CARE ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION ON EIGHT
THREE TWO- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS NO FILE IS NOT
PARTICIPATING ON THIS TODAY SO
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND EEING NOBODY RAISED THEIR
HAND WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
THREE TWO WILL BE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE. FILE WE'RE GOING TO GO
ON TO OUR NEXT BILL WHICH IS SB
NINE TWO SIX ALSO BY SENATOR
DODD ON PRESCRIBED FIRE
LIABILITY THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF NINETY SIX SEEING
NOBODY COME TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR. FOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETY SIX DOT. YOU CAN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE TWO SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
THAT IS. ONE NINE ZERO. I HAVE
NO ONE IN HERE ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO TO OPPOSITION OF NINE TO SIX
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT
THE MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE OPPOSED TO NINE TWO SIX.
YOU CAN OPPOSITION OF ASKING
NINE TWO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE I HAVE NO
ONE IN HERE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND
NINE TO SIX SEEING NO FILE AN NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINETY SIX WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING ON TO S.
B. EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT BY SENATOR
SKINNER ON SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAVE TO PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT TO SUPPORT YOUR ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE HERE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT.
SEVEN EIGHT. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AND ONE MOMENT IF THEY
GATHER LINE NUMBER. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE SEVENTY. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE PAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HAVE A LOOK
AT THEM AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
STATE POLICY AT PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES CALLING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOCATION OF
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS
IN SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LOOK OFF THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SHEET METAL AIR RAIL AND
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION IN
SUPPORT. AND THAT IS ALL THAT I
HAD IN HERE. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION OF S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN ACRES OR ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM SEEING NOBODY COME TO
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE. FOR
OPPOSITION TO S. B. EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT. WE CAN OPPOSITION OF THE
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR FONG.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
I HAVE NO I THINK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT SEEING NO HANDS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON S.
B. TEN EIGHTY THREE SENATOR
SKINNER ON CAL WORKS. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION OF A RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE IN
SUPPORT OF TEN EIGHTY THREE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TEN EIGHTY THREE. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. EIGHT TEN EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. AND ONE MOMENT
TOGETHER LINE NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN
THAT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE.
ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MIKE MCCABE I'M RESIDENTS TO
INVESTORS AND I SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF SENATE BILL. TEN EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION OF TEN
EIGHTY THREE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED ANY THREE NO.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN EIGHTY
THREE. IN OPPOSITION OF THE L.
A. TEN EIGHTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND I
HAVE NO WINNING YEAH ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN EIGHTY
THREE AND SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN EIGHTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON S. B. EIGHT SEVEN NINE
SENATOR WIENER ON TOXICOLOGY
TESTING ON DOGS AND CATS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. SO WE'LL WRITE
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM AT THE
MICROPHONE SO MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SEVEN NINE. WE CAN SUPPORT EVENT
HE EIGHT SEVEN NINE THESE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AT
AGE ONE AND ZERO. I HAVE NO NAME
HERE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT SEVEN NINE
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
OPPOSED IT EIGHT SEVEN NINE
MATTER IS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED EIGHT SEVEN NINE.
SPEAKING OPPOSITION NUMBER SB
EIGHT SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
IF ONE IN HERE ON YOUR PHONE.
AND I HAVE NO WINNING HERE RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB EIGHT SEVEN NINE AND
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT SEVEN NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
SB EIGHT NINETY SEVEN BY SENATOR
Y. CAO SKI ON ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
MY COLLEAGUE IS WAY PRESENTATION
SO WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO SUPPORT EIGHT
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN IN THIS ROOM
SEEING NO ONE AT THE MICROPHONE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
OF S. B. EIGHT NINE SEVEN. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
NINE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THAT IS ONE
THEN. ZERO I HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
NINE SEVEN MODERATORS OR ANYONE
OPPOSED EIGHT NINE SEVEN WELL
IT'S SO THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED TO LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINE MATTER IS OR ANYONE
OPPOSED EIGHT NINE SEVEN. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT
NINE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AT THIS TIME
. AND ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST
LINE. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
DAVID JONES ON BEHALF THE MARIN
COUNTY COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND
COUNCIL MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION.
AND ONE MOMENT FOR AN EXCELLENT.
WE WILL CLOSE TO LINE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD- YEAH. WOMAN ON
THE BEACH RESIDENTS OPPOSE STATE
AND SEVEN THANK.
AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT NINE SEVEN
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE ALSO BY MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR Y. CASCARA BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION. TO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWELVE TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
IN SUPPORT OVER THE PHONE LINE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE. BEACON SUPPORTIVE
S. T. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. YEAH THIS ORDER AND. ONE
ZERO. AND FIRST WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS BUDDY HAN ON BEHALF
OF- HELP ON AMERICA'S UBLIC
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA THAT HERE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AT ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WILL
NOT OPPOSITION OF THE LATEST
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM SO MODERATORS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE. HEY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE. ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
NINE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. NINE
TWENTY KILL PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
I THINK ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL PAYROLL REPORTING
CONSORTIUM IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. WITH THE CAP- BUT THAT'S
ALL THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF S.
B. ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB NINE OH ONE BY
DR PAN ON FLOOD PROTECTION CITY
OF WEST SACRAMENTO FLOOD RISK
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. AND SO
WE'LL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
SUPPORT FOR ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE OH ONE NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
OH ONE. IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THE ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. THREE ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE NO
ENDING YEAH. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF SB NINE OH
ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB NINE A ONE. I
THINK IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. AND I HAVE NO ONE
IN YEAH ALL RIGHT SEEING THOSE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AS
TO NINE OH ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE REMOVED SB NINE FORTY
FIVE BY SENATOR LAYERED ON
FALCONRY. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN
SUPPORT OF NINE FORTY FIVE AND
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE FORTY
FIVE. HEY WE BEEN SUPPORTED SB
NINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN HERE ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
OF NINE FOUR FIVE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB NINE
FORTY FIVE. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
OF AT NINE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN
HERE ALL RIGHT HAVE AN OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND HAVING RECEIVED
NO TESTIMONY AND SEEING OF
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE FORTY
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
S. B. NINE NINE ZERO BY SENATOR
HUESO ON PAROLE THE NET IT IS
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WITH
ALL RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. THAT
IS IN SUPPORT OF NINE NINE ZERO.
YOU CAN PART OF FIFTY NINE NINE
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND AGAIN THAT IS
pHAVE NO ONE IN HERE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF NINE
NINE ZERO THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO NINE NINE ZERO. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION OF ASKING NINE NINE
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ANY HERE
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
AND IF WE JUST TO OPPOSITION-
FOR THE- YEAH WE JUST DID BOTH
ALL RIGHT SO FINO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE NINE
ZERO GO TO SUSPENSE. WE'RE GONNA
SB TEN TWENTY EIGHT ALSO BY
SENATOR HUESO ON STATE PARKS.
VIA MONTEZUMA CITY OF SAN DIEGO
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFERS WAY PRESENTATION. THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
SO WE'LL GO RIGHT TO TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN TWENTY
EIGHT. MODERATORS CAN BEACON
SUPPORTED AT EIGHT TEN TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. THAT'S RIGHT EVERY EVERY
FIXTURE PETER PARKS GIVE IT TO
THE STATE TO FIX UP. I HAVE NO
ONE IN HERE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF TEN TWENTY EIGHT
OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT FOR TO ME
OPPOSED TO TEN TWENTY NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN
TWENTY EIGHT. BEGIN OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO. I HAVE KNOWN IN CARE
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TEN TWENTY
EIGHT AND SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TEN TWENTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON THE S. B. TEN
NINETEEN BY SENATOR GONZALEZ ON
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
SUSPEND TO CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. AND WE WAS ALL
RIGHT IT'S A SUSPENSE CAL IT
WILL GO RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF
SB TEN NINETEEN. YOU CAN
SUPPORTIVE F. EIGHT TEN NINETEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND FIRST WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THE COLD WAR DORMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. AND NEXT LINE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO CAN
OFTEN BE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS AND CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. HI TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS ABIGAIL
ALDRICH THE HELP OF THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER IN SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
LINE TWENTY THE BILL HAS. I'M HI
KATHY ON REPRESENT THE AMERICAN
EXPRESS OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN IN
SUPPORT. IT. EIGHT YEAH THANK
YOU AND- I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOT
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN NINETEEN
THERE'S NOBODY AROUND TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED POTTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB. TEN
NINETEEN. SPEAKING OPPOSITION A
FIFTY TEN NINETEEN THE FIRST ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. I HAVE NO ONE IN CARE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SB TEN NINETEEN WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN NINETEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON SB TEN TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR HER TADO ON HEALTHCARE.
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THE NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND SUPPORT
MODERATE AS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWENTY THREE. BEACON SUPPORTIVE
HE CAN TWENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. I HAVE NO I THINK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF TEN TWENTY THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED OPPOSE BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO TEN TWENTY THREE. IN
OPPOSITION EITHER YOU CAN TWENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I HAVE
NO I THINK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT DECISION OF
TEN TWENTY THREE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN TWENTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB TEN
NINETY FROM HER TADO SENATOR
COTTO ON FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEMS. IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND SUPPORT
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWENTY THREE. TEN TWENTY. OKAY
NINETY I'M SORRY TEN NINE TEN
NINE OF MY MISTAKE. SB TEN
NINETY EIGHT. PARTED S. B. CAN
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I
HAVE NOTING HERE ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF TEN NINETY
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO S. B.
TEN NINETY. WE CAN OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ANY
YEAH ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION ON TEN NINETY
AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN NINETY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON SB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
BY CENTER ARE TRUE LETTER ON
PUBLIC HEALTH GOALS PRIMARY
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS AND-
DRINKING WATER STANDARD IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN
SUPPORT MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. WE CAN
SUPPORTIVE SB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I HAVE NO
ANY YEAH. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. WE CAN
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. THIS PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
WINNING YEAH ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION ON
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR ANSWERING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION IF
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WILL BE UNDER SB ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR JONES ON
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH CARDIAC.
CARDIAC SCREENING PILOT PROGRAM
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WITH
ALL RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE. BEACON
SUPPORTED F. ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR FIRST NUMBER.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS LEE HAWK WITH RESOLUTE ON
BEHALF OF THE ATOMIC VOEPEL MOCK
UP FOR LAKE IN SUPPORT OF AT
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU.
AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE THAT IS
SUPPOSED SB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE.
WE CAN OPPOSITION AFTER ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I HAVE
NO ONE IN HERE ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR COM
LONGER ON PRISON VISITS
VISITATION IT'S DISPENSED
SUSPENSE COP CANDIDATE MY
COLLEAGUES WAY PRESENTATION. AND
WE WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. SHE BEACON
SUPPORTED S. ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IT
THANK. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GATHER NINE NUMBERS. THAT IS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ONE MIN ZERO.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI LYDIA
CAMPBELL CALLING FROM SACRAMENTO
IN STRONG SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE HAVE A LINE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REALLY NOTHING
WE CAN AND WE'RE GOING TO
CALIFORNIA AND CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU. AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. BEGIN
OPPOSITION FF ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
IF PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. I HAVE NO ENDING YEAH ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
WE HAVE NO QUESTION SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ONTO
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG ON ELECTRICITY
ELIGIBLE RENEWABLE ENERGY OR
ENERGY STORAGE RESOURCES IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WITH ALL RIGHT
TO TESTIMONY SUPPORTERS NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATE FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR. FECUND SUPPORTED
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. THE GO TO LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CARLY WALKING CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION ALEXCO WORKERS IN
ADDITION TO THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES AND
SUPPORT ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT HAVE
BEEN DONE TO SUPPORT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OPPOSED. TO
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR.
IN OPPOSITION OF THE ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I HAVE NO IN
HERE I WOULD TAKE IT SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES AND
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES THAT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE LIVING ON SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
ON HOUSING THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. BEACON
SUPPORTED SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I HAVE NO ONE IN HERE
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATE
HEARING ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
. WE CANNOT THE HAITIAN OF THE
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN. ONE NINE
ZERO. WHEN AN AIRLINER FONG. I
HAVE NO ONE IN CARE RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WITH A SUSPENSE
MOVING ON SB TWELVE THIRTY TWO
BY SENATOR ALAN ON SOLID WASTE
TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION OF A
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
AND WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO US SO. WE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
A CHERRY I APOLOGIES I'M IS
GONNA GO ON THE RECORD IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
BY WHAT HOUSEKI ON BEHALF OF
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE AN
ACLU CALIFORNIA I KNOW IT'S NOT
THE BILL AT HAND BUT I DISMISSED
EARLIER AND YOUR NAME- CATALINA
SANCHEZ THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE ARE ON PUBLIC TESTIMONY
OF TWELVE THIRTY TWO THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE ROOM WHO SPEAKING
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE. LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
THIRTY TWO. YOU CAN. IT SB.
THIRTY TWO PLEASE. ONE AND ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. HEY EIGHT TWELVE
THIRTY TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
I HAVE NO ONE IN HERE. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTY. SIR ANYONE OPPOSED SB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE THIRTY TWO. IN OPPOSITION
IT TWELVE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THE TIME. I HAVE NO ONE
IN YEAH ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF TWELVE
THIRTY TWO MODERATE EXCUSE ME-
COLLEAGUES NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE THIRTY TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED BY
SENATOR THE RAZA ON FOSTER YOU
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION MODERN WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED. YOU CAN
SUPPORTIVE SB THIRTEEN HUNDRED.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OPPOSED S. B.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED. IN
OPPOSITION OF THE THIRTEEN
HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. ONE NINE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO IN
HERE ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF S. B.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. B. THIRTEEN
HUNDRED WILL GO TO SUSPEND. THAT
WAS ON FOSTER YOU WILL MOVE ON
TO SB THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD ON SECOND HAND
GOODS TANGIBLE PERSONAL PROPERTY
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MY
COLLEAGUES WAY PRESENTATION. WE
WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN. IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST
LINE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
RENEE THE PADA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
AFFAIRS I AM CONFIDENT I AM
CURRENTLY ON A PRIOR BILLS THAT
I MISSED I'M HERE TO SUPPORT SB
TEN NINETEEN THANK YOU. YEAH A
LOT OF THAT GOING. ANY PORT OF
THIRTEEN AND I HAVE SEEN. I HAVE
NO I DON'T THINK YEAH ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION AT
THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODDERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED. TO THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN. HEY IN OPPOSITION OF
ETHNIC THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO I THINK YOU RIGHT
SEEING NO COMMENTERS AND NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
LEVINE TO SENATOR BRADFORD NEXT
BILL WHICH IS S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUR ON MEAL AND REST
PERIODS FOR HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES.
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MY
COLLEAGUE IS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
SUPPORTERS NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR.
BEACON SUPPORTED SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WOMEN
HERE ON YOUR PHONE. AND I HAVE
NO LINK YOU WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION AND THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
FOUR. HE THE VISION OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE MAN
HERE ON YOUR PHONE. I HAVE NO IN
KILL I WOULD TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B. THIRTEEN. THIRTY FOUR WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR A
TROLL BOTH GONE EXCAVATION THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. AND THE
AUTHOR HAS WAY PRESENTATION AND
WE'LL GO RIGHT PUBLIC TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE. BEACON
SUPPORTED AS A. THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. FIFTY FOUR S. ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
NO IN HERE ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION TO THE SP THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE. COMMA THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY DILLON
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SANITATION AGENCIES
ALL THE MAJOR WASTE WATER
AGENCIES I'LL BE VERY BRIEF THE
ANALYSIS MENTIONED LIKELY
CAUSTIC CALTRANS IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THE COST TO
CITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS FOR HAVING TO MARK NON
PRESSURIZED SEWER LINES WOULD BE
EVEN GREATER- ARE AGENCIES
ESTIMATE THERE ARE LIKELY OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND MILES OF NON
PRESSURIZED SEWER LINES IN THE
STATE SO REQUIRING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MARTY'S LINES
THAT ARE DEEP UNDERGROUND WOULD
BE EXTREMELY COSTLY WITH LITTLE
OR NO- SAFETY BENEFITS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT NO ONE
ELSE IN THIS ROOM OF CLOSE TO
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE. IN OPPOSITION OF F. EIGHT
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. I HAVE NO IN HERE
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE WE'VE HAD NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE WITH A SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL BILL
TODAY SB FOURTEEN FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR CABALLERO ON OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONIES SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE. YOU CAN
SUPPORTIVE SB FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. I HAVE
NO I THINK YEAH. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT SINCE IS THERE
ANYONE OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATE OR ANYONE OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE. WE CAN
OPPOSITION FST FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE THIS PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. ONE NINE ZERO. I
HAVE NO I THINK YEAH ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB FOURTEEN FORTY NINE FIVE
AND NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FOURTEEN FORTY NINE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE THAT CONCLUDES OUR-
AGENDA ITEMS. ALL RIGHT- WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MORE
MINUTES HERE AND THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE ON THE FLOOR SEE
NEXT MONDAY. YOU GOT IT. I WILL
READ ARE CONCLUDING COMMENTS AS
WE WAIT ANOTHER FIVE MINUTES. I
THANK EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. OBVIOUSLY
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE THEM IN. IN FISHEL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MORE MINUTES
AND- THEN WE WILL. GAVELED.
THIS APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING WILL ADJOURN.